have this beautiful look with your most
accurate weather now forecast looking
across at the lights turned back on on
the Las Vegas Strip officially 69
degrees at McCarran anybody else in the
60s let's see the air for space way up
north pretty much around the edges also
down south in the Southwest seven hills
roads ranch anthem everybody else in the
lower 70s I got a feeling we'll drop a
couple of more degrees before things
really do crank up again we were about
10 degrees warmer yesterday than we were
on Monday today will be about 10 degrees
warmer than yesterday I think you get
the picture let's check in now with the
Death Valley it's 74 take away 10 for
Sandy Valley good morning to prompt at
68 you're matching that over in Mesquite
but cooler in Cedar City it's been in
the 20s the past couple of warnings up
in Ely so you consider 36 a little bit
of a warm-up so we only did 87 yesterday
after trying for 88 will go for 96 today
right around normal so far our current
temperature is the low so far this
morning so high-pressure is definitely
under control right now but over the
weekend there will be more wind coming
in for your family and friends the
remnants of what was tropical depression
crystal ball still causing a lot of rain
in the Midwest here is your seven-day
forecast and follow along as we bump you
up to above triple digits tomorrow and
Friday but wind comes in Friday and
Saturday so we drop back to the 90s for
Saturday and Sunday only to bounce back
up above triple digits Monday and
Tuesday